hey it's pete
i'm in jackson hole today and i'm
hanging out with a good friend of mine
mike sussman
and uh mike is the founder of carve
systems
a security consultancy and mike's a
pretty well-known security researcher
in his own right so
um
we actually wrote some powder today hit
the mountain and decided why not squeeze
in a geek talk so
thanks for sitting down and chatting no
i'm happy to be here thanks yeah um we
have an interesting topic lined up
um
mike's gonna
refresh himself a little bit as we're
talking and actually
we even have a little uh fireplace
action so make it a little cozier in
here for the true mountain vibe
totally why not do something different
right
um so we want to talk today about mobile
application security
and what you can do to secure your
mobile apps if you're a developer
how should you be thinking about
security
in terms of mobile devices and mobile
applications
um what are some best practices what are
some architectural issues
um what are what are the main things
that you should be worried about and
concerned about
as you're building and architecting your
application
um so mike
your background is
um as a programmer as a
sometime one-time hacker as a security
consultant
just fill us in a little bit and tell us
how you got interested in mobile so in
the first place a long long time ago i
was an application developer myself
um i
was programming on the microsoft web
technology so classic
asp.com visual c plus plus back in the
day around up until about 2004 when i
made kind of a little shift in my career
and i went to work for
an ssl vpn application firewall vendor
and that's where i started to focus a
little bit more on breaking applications
and having been someone who had written
both secure and insecure applications i
uh
i took to it pretty easily
um
coming out of working for this app
firewall vendor i i went into more of a
pure you know corporate appsec role
and lasted there a little bit before i
just kind of went full on into into
appsec consulting and
you know being a breaker and uh
and someone who helps
uh fix security vulnerabilities so
um and you've spoken at conferences yeah
spoken at black hat and defcon and
cansec west
what's what's the most basic thing that
a software engineer
should realize when they're approaching
mobile application security how is
mobile app security fundamentally
different than regular web app security
for instance so when you're creating a
web application um
we kind of have a little bit of a walled
garden mentality you know we can put
comments in our code and we can you know
do sloppy things because we don't have
time to do them properly and they sit on
our web server and as long as that web
server doesn't get hacked or compromised
uh you know our
our dirty secrets are somewhat safe but
when you're writing a mobile application
it's uh you know it's similar to writing
you know off-the-shelf software that's
going to be you know in a retail box or
that you're going to get on a dvd the
software is going to be in in someone's
hands they're going to have the ability
to reverse engineer it and figure out
how you wrote it and see that okay maybe
you
architected it and implemented it
properly or you made some mistakes with
regards to security and privacy and not
to mention the fact that they have
control of the physical device as well
right which physical security is
sometimes an overlooked aspect of
computer security in general but um most
most
computer
security professionals know that
if you get access to the physical device
in most scenarios it's pretty much game
over sure and you know we have that same
problem with laptops but with laptops we
have additional controls we have full
disk crypto and and things like that and
we have
uh access control you know we have
domain policies and there's a lot of
hardening that can be done to a
corporate device or even a personal
device a personal laptop that if you
happen to lose it
you know
your your risk is somewhat controlled
but with these mobile devices they're
not as mature we don't have a lot of the
the controls and the ability to harden
or lock down these devices as we do with
a laptop so if you're writing an
application that deals with potentially
sensitive data like credit card data or
even just email
how you store that data on the device uh
becomes very important
um if that device is lost or stolen or
even jailbroken now
uh
you know now that we're developing uh on
these sort of sandboxed environments on
the mobile devices
there's sometimes an error of okay well
the the os is going to handle this stuff
so we don't need to worry about it as
developers
but
once a user jailbreaks their device
a lot of that security is removed so now
your application is in a far more
hostile environment than you originally
thought it expected it to be